German Chancellor Angela Merkel appeared
more than happy to promote her agenda in
the crowded Hall in Davos I think we
should understand our national interest
in a way that we think about the
interest of others and from that create
win-win situations that are the
precondition for multilateralism that
was apparently aimed at politicians like
Donald Trump who put the interests of
their own country first japan's Prime
Minister Shinzo Abe a also made it clear
in Davos he remains committed to open
markets no growth without free trade Ave
focused above all on digitization and
borderless data traffic the engine for
gloss if you think about it is fueled no
longer by gasoline but born more by
digital data the hustle and bustle in
Davos is as international as usual but
the atmosphere is more subdued brexit
climate change stronger nationalism
instead of the world improving the
future seems increasingly uncertain the
trade conflict between China and the USA
hasn't been resolved either and China is
pleading for a reprieve the US and
Chinese economies can't live without
each other that's already the reality so
the conclusion is that the relationship
must be mutually beneficial and win-win
cooperation serves the interests of both
sides while confrontation harms them
this is a basic principle
everything sounds reasonable improve the
world treat each other fairly everyone
here agrees but the world outside of
Davos looks different DWS ban fur zulan
is there at the World Economic Forum Ben
the trade frictions between the US and
China the world's two top economies and
is impacting global trade routes how's
it shaping the debate in Davos basically
pick any company along the Promenade
here that's represented here at Davos
and they'll talk about the trade war to
you they're all affected in some way or
could be affected eventually as an
economist told me this morning we could
see global effects from this trade war
for decades from now which sounds pretty
dramatic but we're talking about the top
two economies facing off against each
other
and there are not only companies caught
in the crossfire but whole countries
like Australia for example which is
wedged between Beijing and Washington
I've got the finance minister from
Australia which he has common with us
what is that like being stuck between
the two we don't seared that why we
obviously have a longstanding friendship
strategic alliance and trade and
investment relationship with the United
States and in more recent times China
has become a most important to buy a
trading partner but you were committed
and we believe we can continue to
maintain good relations both with the
United States and with China you may see
it that way but you sure are feeling the
effects of this trade war I mean we're
seeing the first signs of a recession
something most Australians wouldn't even
know what it is because you've had what
27 years of positive growth how are you
planning to head off a recession well
you know we do strain economy continues
to grow and we expect the Australian
economy to continue to grow we are into
our 20th year of continuous growth about
three percent growth per annum is what
we expect moving forward the
unemployment rate is down to five
percent widest growth is starting to
pick up yes I mean there are global
economic headwinds we're very mindful of
that their downside risks are very
mindful of that to the extent that they
tried attention so we certainly would
like to see the resolve we were very
encouraged by the
progress and certainly the momentum that
was generated in Verna's hours in the
wake of the g20 leaders summit between
President Trump and president gzipping
so like others we are very interested in
seeing any trade tensions resolved in an
orderly fashion as soon as possible
you're still planning to write a budget
surplus after a decade of deficits isn't
that a bit late well when we came into
government five and a half years ago we
inherited a weakening economy rising
unemployment in a rapidly deteriorating
budget position today that the economy
is stronger the growth outlook is better
employment growth is strong the
unemployment rate is well below who was
anticipated it would be and indeed the
budget is in a stronger and improving
position and our forecast definitely
shows that we expect to return to
surplus in 20 19 20 if you look at our
last two financial years our actual
performance has been materially better
than what was forecast in our last two
budgets and certainly we haven't seen
any data that would contradict what we
expect will happen into the future well
I don't want to correct you but when I
look at the figures I see weak wages
slowing housing rising debt couldn't
life get difficult for your embattled
p.m. Scott Morrison he's new on the
scene well let me tell you why just
growth would be much lower
if we hadn't implemented our agenda for
stronger growth in more jobs I mean by
any measure the unemployment right at 5%
is well below where it was when we came
into government well below where people
thought it would head given the
circumstances we inherited and indeed
the more recent data shows that widest
growth is picking up I mean if we
continue to increase the level of
employment in Australia which we expect
will happen and labor supply continues
to tighten up of course we will expect
riders to continue to increase I mean
there'll be an election in a few months
time we will be putting our economic
agenda forth the alternative government
will be putting theirs forward and the
Australian people get to decide that is
democracy Australian Finance Minister
Matias comment thank you very much or is
it good to talk to you
you